Jake:这一个
Jake: This one.
Jake:一个插头是吧
Jake: One plug, right?
Shure: 是的然后咱们弄几个锅
Shure: Yeah, and then let's get a few pots.
Shure: 是弄一个锅还是两个锅
Shure: Should we get one pot or two pots?
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake?
Shure: 一个锅
Shure: One pot.
Jake:有两个锅
Jake: We have two pots.
Shure: 对有两
Shure: Right, we have two.
Jake:这个不用垫
Jake: This one doesn't need a mat.
Lucia: 他们居然真的有运动过这个房子
Lucia: They actually did exercise in this house.
Shure: 个锅那就用一个这个吧先
Shure: Let's use this one first then.
Shure: 用两个锅
Shure: Using two pots.
Jake:一个不用电
Jake: One doesn't need electricity.
Jake:就一个用电
Jake: Only one needs electricity.
Shure: 底下还有一个不用电的
Shure: There's another one that doesn't need electricity underneath.
Jake:咱没那么多差异
Jake: We don't have that many differences.
Shure: 这气好像不是那么多问题
Shure: The gas doesn't seem to be much of an issue.
Shure: 应该也不大
Shure: Shouldn't be a big deal.
Jake:这个是
Jake: This is...
Lucia: 冰箱的电源吗
Lucia: Is this the fridge's power source?
Jake:可以用对
Jake: You can use it, yeah.
Jake:但是插墙上就行
Jake: But just plug it into the wall.
Lucia: 你在这边
Lucia: You stay here.
Lucia: 我拿上来了
Lucia: I brought it up.
Jake:看一看还有看还有多少
Jake: Take a look and see how much is left.
Alice:这个插座上面
Alice: On this socket.
Shure: 对这个插座上面
Shure: Yeah, on this socket.
Alice:上面插排插插排插排插插排
Alice: There's an extension cord on top of the power strip.
Alice:会不会有安全隐患
Alice: Could this be a safety hazard?
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Lucia: 不会不会
Lucia: No, no.
Shure: 死不了放心真的
Shure: You won't die, don't worry, really.
Jake:这个大家都是这么火的
Jake: Everyone does it like this.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 都已经如此生活30年了
Shure: We've been living like this for 30 years.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 没事这个不会的啦这个没问题的
Lucia: No worries, this is totally fine.
Shure: 没问题
Shure: No problem.
Jake:外边都是这么搞
Jake: Everyone does it this way.
Jake:并且我们这个是民牌插足
Jake: And we use well-known brands.
Alice:公牛是吗
Alice: Bull brand, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice:看到公牛我放心了
Alice: Seeing Bull brand makes me feel better.
Shure: 然后就是坐这的同学稍微注意一些
Shure: So, those sitting here, just be a bit careful.
Tasha: 哈哈由我来进行一个开箱仪式吗
Tasha: Haha, should I do an unboxing ceremony?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes.
Tasha: 好好
Tasha: Alright, alright.
Lucia: 开箱的工作交给你了
Lucia: I'll leave the unboxing to you.
Shure: 这白菜洗没洗呢
Shure: Has this cabbage been washed?
Lucia: 我负责取快递你负责开箱
Lucia: I'll pick up the packages, you do the unboxing.
Alice:还没呢
Alice: Not yet.
Shure: 那要不洗洗一下子
Shure: Then let's wash it quickly.
Alice:确实得洗
Alice: It does need to be washed.
Alice:金针菇啥的也得洗一下
Alice: The enoki mushrooms need to be washed too.
Alice:这种也得过一下
Alice: This kind needs a rinse too.
Lucia: 谢谢你
Lucia: Thank you.
Shure: 慢得和你走到散
Shure: Slowly, and walk with you.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Huh?
Tasha: 啊哈
Tasha: Aha.
Alice:没洗手
Alice: Didn't wash hands.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure: 谢谢
Shure: Thanks.
Shure: 虽然没洗手
Shure: Although I didn't wash my hands
Shure: 但是不干不净
Shure: But you know, the more germs the better
Shure: 喝了有病
Shure: Drinking it will make you sick
Tasha: 他这个
Tasha: This guy
Jake:我怎么知道我订单尾号是什么
Jake: How would I know what the last digits of my order number are?
Tasha: 感觉像诈骗
Tasha: Feels like a scam
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:不是不是订单尾号快递
Jake: No, no, it's not the order number, it's the delivery
Tasha: 什么时候吃晚饭
Tasha: When are we having dinner?
Lucia: 快
Lucia: Soon
Shure: 打算在群里喊一下
Shure: Planning to shout it out in the group
Shure: 回家吃饭了
Shure: Time to go home for dinner
Alice:在群里吗
Alice: In the group chat?
Jake:没吧没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, not in the group chat
Alice:可以再来一个吗他不是不够吗
Alice: Can we get another one? Isn't it not enough?
Tasha: 是啊
Tasha: Yeah
Tasha: 没事不是每个人都要吃到一个
Tasha: It's okay, not everyone needs to get one
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice:那我再来一个吧那个那个好看
Alice: Then I'll get another one, that one looks nice
Tasha: 啊这个能至于
Tasha: Ah, is it really necessary?
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Alice:我也觉得
Alice: I think so too
Alice:因为他没有被压
Alice: Because it wasn't pressed
Tasha: 呵
Tasha: Heh
Shure: 啊稍微稍微冲一下
Shure: Ah, just rinse it a bit
Shure: 虽然这应该是干净的
Shure: Even though it should be clean
Tasha: 其实我想问这个
Tasha: Actually, I wanted to ask
Tasha: 那个瓦斯罐应该装在哪
Tasha: Where should the gas canister be placed?
Shure: 装瓦装进去了
Shure: The canister is already placed
Tasha: 装进去吧
Tasha: It's placed in?
Tasha: 嗯行
Tasha: Okay, got it
Shure: 我宿舍就有
Shure: I have one in my dorm
Shure: 一个非非常不安全
Shure: It's very, very unsafe though
Tasha: 我没有
Tasha: I don't have one
Shure: 大家不要学
Shure: Don't follow my example
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly
Shure: 也可以烧水的哦
Shure: It can also be used to boil water
Shure: 电水热水壶
Shure: An electric kettle
Tasha: 月饼
Tasha: Mooncake
Shure: 还在楼下
Shure: Still downstairs.
Tasha: 他们还有3个人是吧
Tasha: There are still three of them, right?
Alice:我们学校前一段还着火了
Alice: Our school caught fire a while ago.
Tasha: 那好吧
Tasha: Oh, okay.
Jake:为什么呢
Jake: Why?
Jake:用插板吃火锅
Jake: Using the wipe board to eat hotpot.
Alice:嗯有人吸烟
Alice: Someone was smoking.
Alice:哦这好像不让说的
Alice: Oh, I think we're not supposed to talk about this.
Alice:无所谓哈哈
Alice: Whatever, haha.
Alice:没关系啊
Alice: It's no big deal.
Jake:贵校不让说
Lucia: 关系没事他会把这段删掉的哈
Lucia: It's fine, he'll edit this part out.
Alice:不删也行无所谓
Alice: It's fine if he doesn't, whatever.
Shure: 有人逼逼哈哈哈
Shure: Someone's babbling, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:吧
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 毕一
Tasha: Beep.
Lucia: 那我给你手动做音效
Lucia: Let me make the sound effect for you.
Shure: 然后他在逼逼的时候他逼逼的哈哈
Shure: When he's babbling, he just keeps babbling, haha.
Lucia: 你现在说吧
Lucia: You can talk now.
Lucia: 哈哈哈咪哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha, me haha.
Alice:哈哈咦
Alice: Haha, oh.
Jake:咦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:无所谓这个
Alice: It's not a big deal.
Lucia: 我们学校之前也有过但好像是电动车
Lucia: Our school had a similar incident, but it was an electric bike.
Alice:然后那个救护车开到楼下了
Alice: Then the ambulance arrived downstairs.
Alice:我还在睡觉
Alice: I was still sleeping.
Alice:完全没有听到
Alice: I didn't hear anything.
Alice:他们在群里一直在吵我们要不要跑
Alice: They were arguing in the group chat whether we should run.
Alice:要不要跑
Alice: Should we run?
Alice:没有听到声音
Alice: I didn't hear a thing.
Lucia: 大家精神状态都很稳定吗
Lucia: Was everyone mentally stable?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 小的不用跑大的跑不了
Lucia: The small ones don't need to run, the big ones can't run.
Jake:鼓手是
Jake: The drummer is...
Jake:就是是吧
Jake: Right?
Shure: 好
Shure: Yes.
Jake:哈哈啊
Jake: Haha, yeah.
Shure: 可以可以
Shure: Sure, sure.
Jake:打击乐手
Jake: The percussionist.
Alice:这点有餐盘啥的吗
Alice: Are there any plates here?
Alice:还是楼下有
Alice: Or are they downstairs?
Tasha: 这好像也有
Tasha: I think we have some here too.
Alice:洗一下吧
Alice: Let's wash them.
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No, we don't.
Alice:这个不用洗
Alice: This one doesn't need washing.
Lucia: sorry不是这个
Lucia: Sorry, not this one.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 别的都不用好像
Tasha: I think the others don't need it either.
Alice:这个需要吗
Alice: Do we need this one?
Alice:嗯拿碟装吧
Alice: Hmm, let's use a dish for this.
Lucia: 嗯点的话不够
Lucia: Hmm, if we order, it won't be enough.
Lucia: 咱有8个人
Lucia: We have 8 people.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:你是不是得下楼亲
Alice: Do you need to go downstairs?
Alice:有没有大一点
Alice: Is there a bigger one?
Lucia: 妙妙小工具
Lucia: A little tool.
Alice:我想要那个
Alice: I want that one.
Alice:我洗白菜啊
Alice: I'm going to wash the cabbage.
Lucia: 啊你说你说碗吗
Lucia: Ah, you mean the bowl?
Alice:大碗对
Alice: The big bowl, yes.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Alice:我洗白菜
Alice: I'm washing the cabbage.
Lucia: 这个碗我前两天洗过
Lucia: I washed this bowl a couple of days ago.
Lucia: 我涮一下就可以
Lucia: I'll just rinse it.
Lucia: 对但其他的
Lucia: Yes, but the others...
Lucia: 这上面的碗应该还没怎么用过
Lucia: These bowls up here haven't been used much.
Lucia: 我先都拿出来
Lucia: I'll take them all out first.
Lucia: 就是先拿8个这个小碗
Lucia: Let's take 8 small bowls first.
Alice:白菜手撕的好吃
Alice: Hand-torn cabbage tastes great.
Alice:谁懂
Alice: Who knows?
Lucia: 啊太好了有白菜
Lucia: Ah, great, we have cabbage.
Lucia: 我还以为白菜咱昨天用完了呢
Lucia: I thought we used all the cabbage yesterday.
Alice:我只用了叶没用包
Alice: I only used the leaves, not the core.
Alice:这是
Alice: This is...
Lucia: 我到楼下看看楼下的碗够不够
Lucia: I'll go check downstairs to see if there are enough bowls.
Lucia: 要楼下碗够
Lucia: If there are enough bowls downstairs...
Lucia: 把楼下碗拿上来算了
Lucia: I'll just bring them up.
Lucia: 要不然话还得再涮一次太麻烦了
Lucia: Otherwise, we'll have to dip it again, which is too much trouble.
Shure: 哦我们直接这样
Shure: Oh, we'll just do it like this.
Shure: 走一下线
Shure: Let's run the line.
Tasha: 走一下线
Tasha: Run the line.
Katrina: 还有一些小狗
Katrina: There are also some puppies.
Jake:你的这是什么
Jake: What's this of yours?
Shure: 回来了
Shure: I'm back.
Jake:三颗钱还是什么
Jake: Three pieces of money or what?
Katrina: 非常非常丰富
Katrina: Very, very abundant.
Jake:三三颗出伪金币吗还是
Jake: Three fake coins or what?
Katrina: 哈哈哈都有
Katrina: Hahaha, everything.
Jake:什么都有
Jake: Everything?
Jake:很多是吧
Jake: A lot, right?
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Jake:要火要火
Jake: It's going to be popular.
Choiszt: 这个厕所有人么
Choiszt: Is there anyone in this bathroom?
Shure: 没人吧
Shure: I don't think so.
Katrina: 哇团建的感觉
Katrina: Wow, it feels like team building.
Jake:一会开吃了再结束吧
Jake: Let's finish eating before we wrap up.
Jake:就是把这个都拆开
Jake: Just open all of these.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Shure: 我们来来个同学帮我一下
Shure: Can someone help me with this?
Jake:开吃就
Jake: Start eating then.
Jake:来要干啥
Jake: What are we doing?
Shure: 直接倒到那里面
Shure: Just pour it in there.
Alice:这啥玩意怎么洗不掉呢
Alice: What is this? Why can't I wash it off?
Shure: 省得我一点一点接了是吧
Shure: So I don't have to do it bit by bit, right?
Katrina: 诶从哪搞两锅啊
Jake:哦哦走赶走
Jake: Oh, oh, go ahead.
Shure: 然后这个拿着吧
Shure: And then hold this.
Tasha: 就有啊哦
Tasha: There is, oh.
Shure: 别别让这个粘着那什么
Shure: Don't let this stick to that.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Katrina: 我以为要借
Katrina: I thought we had to borrow it.
Choiszt: 你们真喝这个么
Choiszt: Are you guys really drinking this?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice:然我说这洗不掉
Alice: Then I said this won't wash off.
Jake:你别碰他
Jake: Don't touch it.
Alice:这什么玩意
Alice: What is this thing?
Jake:就这样就行了
Jake: Just like this, it's fine.
Lucia: 有就是有的菜叶子上它就
Lucia: Some of the vegetable leaves have...
Jake:就没必要了
Jake: It's not necessary.
Lucia: 就长这样还是怎么回事
Lucia: Does it grow like this, or what?
Lucia: 我们家洗菜也是
Lucia: We wash vegetables at home too.
Jake:是没必要了
Jake: It's not necessary.
Lucia: 就是有时候这个东西它是洗不掉的
Lucia: Sometimes this stuff just can't be washed off.
Alice:摸摸
Alice: Touch it.
Jake:倒个数据呗
Jake: Pour the data.
Lucia: 应该它就长这样
Lucia: It probably grows like this.
Alice:好像长上去了一样
Alice: It looks like it grew on it.
Jake:数据倒了倒了
Jake: The data is poured.
Lucia: 对它就长这样
Lucia: Yeah, it grows like this.
Alice:好你给我做个见
Alice: Alright, you be my witness.
Alice:证啊
Alice: Okay?
Alice:放心吧我确实洗了
Alice: Don't worry, I did wash it.
Lucia: 好放心吧
Lucia: Okay, don't worry.
Lucia: 他就长这样
Lucia: It grows like this.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Katrina: 哇哦
Katrina: Wow.
Shure: 这放放顶上
Shure: Put this on top.
Shure: 不然话我一会钻不过去
Shure: Otherwise, I can't get through later.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 我对我自己几斤几两非常有点逼数
Shure: I know exactly my own weight.
Shure: 你知道吧
Shure: You know that, right?
Lucia: 我踩着啥了刚才
Lucia: What did I step on just now?
Tasha: 嘶呦呦呦
Tasha: Oh, oh, oh.
Shure: 呦呦呦
Shure: Oh, oh, oh.
Lucia: 你小心小心
Lucia: Be careful, careful.
Lucia: 主要是别碰到接口什么的地方
Lucia: Just don't touch the connection points.
Katrina:  没事擦一下吧
Katrina: It's okay, just wipe it.
Lucia: 呃楼上是不是没有抹布好像哎有
Lucia: Uh, is there no cloth upstairs? Oh, there is.
Jake:哎
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 这个水明显少了
Tasha: This water is obviously less.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 没事我们一会拿那个开水直接补吧
Shure: It's okay, we'll add hot water later.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:用娃哈哈的水
Jake: Use Wahaha water.
Katrina: 先拿抹布擦
Katrina: Wipe it with a cloth first.
Lucia: 呃
Lucia: Uh
Jake:啊用娃哈哈的水
Jake: Ah, use Wahaha water
Tasha: 就是说他的水很健康的感觉
Tasha: It's like his water feels really healthy
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Lucia: OK实验室用水
Lucia: OK, lab water
Jake:哈哈哈没有没有
Jake: Hahaha, no no
Jake:我乱说的
Jake: I was just joking
Katrina: 想喝个饮料
Katrina: I want to have a drink
Jake:本身我们还有一个环节
Jake: Actually, we have another segment
Jake:就是给你们五六种这种矿泉水
Jake: We're going to give you five or six types of mineral water
Jake:让你们去分
Jake: For you to distinguish
Shure: 啊可以啊
Shure: Oh, sounds good
Katrina: 这是你设计的某种游戏吗
Katrina: Is this some kind of game you designed?
Lucia: 然后呢谁先把这些水喝完谁是赢家吗
Lucia: And then whoever finishes the water first is the winner?
Jake:谁能分辨得出来
Jake: Whoever can tell them apart
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow
Shure: 没问题
Shure: No problem
Shure: 万事俱备
Shure: Everything's ready
Shure: 只他娘的欠东风
Shure: Just missing the final touch
Shure: 东风是什么呢
Shure: What's the final touch?
Shure: 东风就是火锅底料
Shure: It's the hotpot base
Jake:为什么
Jake: Why?
Tasha: 火锅底料呢
Tasha: The hotpot base?
Tasha: 那个那个所有的料的那个袋子
Tasha: The bag with all the ingredients
Lucia: 调料的袋子
Lucia: The seasoning bag
Tasha: 哦对
Tasha: Oh right
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Isn't it?
Katrina: 在楼下
Tasha: 是不是还要拿一些
Tasha: Should we get some more?
Tasha: 8个碗 8个碟
Tasha: Eight bowls, eight plates
Lucia: 呃碗有但盘子不够咱就用小碗吧
Lucia: Uh, we have bowls but not enough plates, let's use small bowls
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Lucia: 因为他这的盘子都是那种大一点的
Lucia: Because the plates here are a bit bigger
Lucia: 而且好像没有8个
Lucia: And there aren't eight of them
Lucia: 至少楼上没有
Lucia: At least not upstairs
Lucia: 不过小碗已经都拿出来了
Lucia: But the small bowls are already out
Tasha: 就拿碗吧
Tasha: Let's just use bowls then
Lucia: 对然后那有3个是楼下洗过
Lucia: Yes, and three of them were washed downstairs
Lucia: 我直接拿上来了
Lucia: I brought them up directly
Tasha: 一二三四五五个
Tasha: One, two, three, four, five, five of them
Lucia: 然后对然后
Lucia: And then, yeah.
Tasha: 再拿三个碗
Tasha: Get three more bowls.
Lucia: 呃池子里应该还有几个
Lucia: Uh, there should be a few more in the sink.
Lucia: 反正我刚把底下都拿出来了
Lucia: Anyway, I just took out the ones from below.
Lucia: 我先去拿一下那个调料
Lucia: I'll go get the seasoning first.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Sure.
Tasha: 帮我把菜端过去
Tasha: Help me carry the dishes over.
Tasha: 吃饭也要开棚额呵
Tasha: Even for a meal, we need to set up the tent.
Jake:今天比较富裕
Jake: We're pretty well off today.
Shure: 有有一个
Shure: Yeah, there's one.
Jake:今天是富裕上
Jake: Today we're well off.
Shure: 要变成纯清汤
Shure: It's gonna turn into a clear soup.
Katrina: 这就一包啊
Katrina: This is just one pack?
Shure: 对这就一包
Shure: Yeah, it's just one pack.
Tasha: 一包不能拆成两包用吗
Tasha: Can't we split one pack into two?
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh...
Tasha: 他这个是写3-5人吃
Tasha: It says it's for 3-5 people.
Shure: 其实也不是不行
Shure: Actually, it could work.
Katrina: 对他应该是一锅的量
Katrina: Yeah, it's probably meant for one pot.
Tasha: 怎么办
Tasha: What should we do?
Katrina: 然后就分成两个半
Katrina: Then just split it in half.
Tasha: 我也撕开
Tasha: I'll tear it open too.
Shure: 我们我们吃辣的水平是什么样的
Shure: How well do we handle spicy food, everyone?
Shure: 家人们
Shure: Family?
Katrina: 我很能吃辣
Katrina: I can handle very spicy food.
Shure: OK四个全
Shure: OK, all four.
Shure: 下一个里
Shure: Into the next one.
Katrina: 哈哈哈总有刁民想害朕
Katrina: Hahaha, there's always someone trying to harm me.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Shure: 辣辣不死你
Shure: Spicy enough to kill you.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha.
Shure: 明天不用拍摄
Shure: No filming tomorrow.
Shure: 大家都在厕所
Shure: Everyone will be in the bathroom.
Tasha: 那那就各分一半吧
Tasha: Then let's split it in half.
Shure: 哎呦呦
Shure: Oh dear.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Tasha: 各分一半了
Tasha: It's split in half now.
Shure: 行行行这就各分一半吧
Shure: Okay, okay, let's just split it in half.
Katrina: 强制下班喽case
Katrina: Forced to clock out early, case closed.
Tasha: 那这个火锅底料反正是4块
Tasha: So, this hotpot base is 4 pieces.
Tasha: 不如一个里面下两块
Tasha: How about putting two pieces in one?
Shure: 就我一个人下两块
Shure: Just me putting two pieces in?
Katrina: 可以
Katrina: Sure.
Shure: 这哪到哪
Shure: What difference does it make?
Shure: 撒撒嘴吧就是
Shure: It's just for a taste.
Katrina: 刚从成都回来
Katrina: Just came back from Chengdu.
Tasha: 一个是两
Tasha: One is two...
Tasha: 一个锅是下两块
Tasha: One pot takes two pieces.
Tasha: 一个锅是下半袋
Tasha: One pot takes half a bag.
Shure: OK那那个下到那个里
Shure: OK, then put it in there.
Lucia: 啊下半袋的意思是
Lucia: Ah, half a bag means...
Lucia: 是这个里面少下一块吗
Lucia: Does it mean putting one piece less?
Shure: 额不是不是菌汤的内个
Shure: Uh no, no, it's for the mushroom soup.
Lucia: 啊OK OK那这个也是拆开放到这里面
Lucia: Ah, OK OK, so we also open this and put it in here.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Got it.
Lucia: 那我就拆了
Lucia: Then I'll open it.
Tasha: 那我就放这个
Tasha: Then I'll put this in.
Tasha: 不要让两种味道混合
Tasha: Don't let the two flavors mix.
Shure: i missing you my honey
Shure: I missing you my honey.
Shure: don t you
Shure: Don't you...
Shure: （歌词）我是一个被你没犹豫的小丑
Shure: (Lyrics) I am a clown you never hesitated about.
Shure: tell me
Shure: Tell me.
Lucia: 怎么只有这一锅水最多
Lucia: Why does this pot have the most water?
Katrina: 哎呀
Katrina: Oh dear.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Tasha: 啊这怎么办
Tasha: Ah, what to do?
Shure: 什么一袋
Shure: What one bag?
Katrina: 怎么了
Katrina: What happened?
Tasha: 只有一袋
Tasha: Only one bag.
Shure: 什么一袋不行吧
Shure: What one bag? That's not enough.
Tasha: 我的建议是把这个袋子撕开
Tasha: My suggestion is to tear this bag open.
Tasha: 然后倒一半
Tasha: And pour half in.
Shure: 这无需撕开
Shure: No need to tear it open.
Shure: 说明他不应该撕开
Shure: It says not to tear it open.
Tasha: 那怎么办
Tasha: Then what?
Shure: 随便
Shure: Whatever.
Shure: 小公鸡点到谁我就选谁好啊
Shure: I'll choose whoever the little rooster points to, alright?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 那这个锅的菌汤该有多么的孤单呀
Tasha: Then how lonely this pot of mushroom soup would be.
Tasha: 啊煮一半把它捞出来放这个锅里
Tasha: Ah, cook half and scoop it out to put in this pot.
Shure: 哈哈哈流动料包
Shure: Hahaha, the mobile feed bag.
Lucia: 失策早知道两个锅当时应该买两包
Lucia: It was a mistake. We should have bought two packs for the two pots.
Shure: 哦你在切东西
Shure: Oh, you're chopping stuff.
Shure: 厕所有人吗
Shure: Is someone in the bathroom?
Shure: anyone
Shure: Anyone?
Alice:应该是没有
Shure: come in
Shure: Come in.
Lucia: 没有人
Lucia: No one.
Shure: 我要进来喽
Shure: I'm coming in.
Tasha: 妈呀
Tasha: Oh my god.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 好多预热啊哈哈哈
Lucia: So much preheating, hahaha.
Jake:严谨
Jake: Precise.
Shure: 嘿嘿嘿
Shure: Hehehe.
Lucia: 3次握手才能确定
Lucia: It takes three handshakes to confirm.
Lucia: 正在进行握手
Lucia: Currently shaking hands.
Shure: i'm missing you my honey don't you
Shure: I'm missing you, my honey, don't you?
Lucia: 我觉得我们家网经常握手它就握不
Lucia: I think our internet often shakes hands and then it doesn't connect.
Shure: 这只扔了
Shure: This one is thrown away.
Lucia: 上了
Lucia: Connected.
Shure: 我是一个变忧郁的小丑
Shure: I'm a melancholic clown.
Shure: 我们那个河马的那些袋子拿一个
Shure: Let's take one of those bags from Hema.
Shure: 然后当一个垃圾袋吧
Shure: And use it as a trash bag.
Shure: 哎你就在那弄
Shure: Hey, you do that.
Shure: 那你先弄着
Shure: You go ahead.
Lucia: 盒马袋子还有吗
Lucia: Are there any Hema bags left?
Shure: 有吧应该
Shure: There should be.
Lucia: 哎我把我手机又撂哪
Lucia: Oh, where did I put my phone?
Lucia: 哎算放那了
Lucia: Oh, just leave it there.
Shure: 我们
Shure: Let's...
Shure: 放点电影看吧
Shure: Watch a movie.
Shure: 大家想看什么类型的电影吗
Shure: What kind of movie do you guys want to watch?
Alice:看一搞笑的脱口秀
Alice: Let's watch a funny stand-up comedy.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 那我们就看
Shure: Then we'll watch...
Shure: 就看
Shure: Watch...
Shure: 一些下饭的
Shure: Some appetizing shows.
Shure: 哎我的电脑在哪里
Shure: Hey, where's my laptop?
Shure: 我看见了
Shure: I see it.
Shure: 我刚刚拿上来
Shure: I just brought it up.
Shure: 看见我的电脑吗
Shure: Have you seen my computer?
Shure: 在这里吗
Shure: Is it here?
Shure: 大脑的配合我却从不相信
Shure: I never believe in the cooperation of the brain.
Lucia: behold
Lucia: Behold.
Shure: 好啊好啊
Shure: Alright, alright.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Shure: 他拿了一个大袋子
Shure: He took a big bag.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Shure: 哪边水不够我们再补一点
Shure: If there's not enough water on that side, we can add some more.
Lucia: 我觉得这这是不是俩都有点少看起来
Lucia: I think both of these look a bit insufficient.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Tasha: 嗯哼哼
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Shure: 是不是应该拿个小盘
Shure: Should we get a small plate?
Shure: 这样然后这个是辣锅烧是吧
Shure: So this is the spicy pot, right?
Lucia: 嗯辣锅里
Lucia: Yes, in the spicy pot.
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Alright.
Shure: 天啊太气
Shure: Oh my, so angry.
Shure: 把那个门关上吧你们
Shure: Close that door, you guys.
Lucia: 哦微
Lucia: Oh, Tasha.
Shure: 不然话会窜进去味的
Shure: Otherwise, the smell will get in.
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Lucia: 微你的门或者我帮你关
Lucia: Tasha, your door, or I can close it for you.
Lucia: 如果你不介意的话
Lucia: If you don't mind.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Shure: 关好哦大家
Shure: Close it properly, everyone.
Lucia: 我看看我那边啊
Lucia: Let me check my side.
Lucia: 我把我那边也关上
Lucia: I'll close my side too.
Alice:你们介意我把这个魔芋直接拽成
Alice: Do you mind if I just pull this konjac?
Shure: 不介意拽吧
Shure: I don't mind, go ahead and pull.
Shure: 我不介意
Shure: I don't mind.
Shure: 有介意的吗
Shure: Does anyone mind?
Lucia: 不介意
Lucia: I don't mind.
Shure: 他们不敢介意了好拽吧
Shure: They don't dare to mind, go ahead and pull.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 对我们觉得拽着香
Shure: Yes, we think it smells good when pulled.
Tasha: 纸
Tasha: Paper.
Shure: 就像手撕白菜一样
Shure: Just like hand-torn cabbage.
Lucia: 哦原来魔芋块是长这样的
Lucia: Oh, so this is what konjac chunks look like.
Shure: i'm missing you my honey
Shure: I'm missing you, my honey.
Lucia: 小心手要不要把那个盘
Lucia: Be careful with your hand, do you want to use that plate?
Lucia: 案板是在楼下是吗
Lucia: The cutting board is downstairs, right?
Lucia: 我再去拿一下好了
Lucia: I'll go get it.
Alice:没事我已经切完了
Alice: No worries, I've already finished cutting.
Lucia: 啊那行
Lucia: Ah, okay then.
Alice:还有什么要弄的
Alice: Is there anything else that needs to be done?
Tasha: 好像没有了喔呕
Tasha: Seems like there's nothing else.
Alice:坐你旁边吧有纸吗
Alice: Can I sit next to you? Do you have any tissues?
Alice:再来一个吧谢谢
Alice: Can I get another one? Thanks.
Alice:我感觉我快没有吃蠢鼠
Alice: I feel like I'm almost out of dumpling wrappers.
Tasha: 嗯蘸料呢哦
Tasha: Hmm, how about the dipping sauce?
Tasha: 蘸料是拿来了吗
Tasha: Did you bring the dipping sauce?
Alice:山药是不是还搁底下呢
Alice: Is the yam still downstairs?
Lucia: 蘸料刚才好像修硕已经开了
Lucia: Looks like Shure already opened the dipping sauce earlier.
Alice:是不是在底下呀
Alice: Is it downstairs?
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Tasha: 醋碟油碟
Tasha: The vinegar and oil dishes.
Shure: 呃都我只把麻酱给卸了
Shure: Uh, I only opened the sesame sauce.
Alice:没有油条就麻酱
Alice: No oil sticks, just sesame sauce.
Lucia: 蘸料你是不是打开了一个
Lucia: Did you open one of the dipping sauces?
Tasha: 买了油买了
Tasha: We bought the oil.
Alice:我没有醋吗
Alice: Do I not have any vinegar?
Shure: 其他的还还没弄
Shure: Haven't dealt with the others yet.
Lucia: 呃有点买了一个小的
Lucia: Uh, I think I bought a small one.
Lucia: 我去把它拿上来
Lucia: I'll go get it.
Tasha: 嗯油碟醋碟
Shure: 大家想看什么呢
Shure: What do you all want to see?
Shure: 大家想看什么呀
Lucia: 那个麻将我不太清楚放哪了
Lucia: I'm not sure where the sesame sauce is.
Lucia: 但是这两个可以拿上来
Lucia: But I can bring these two up.
Shure: 放在楼下的这个这个地方
Shure: It's downstairs in that place.
Lucia: 啊确定吗
Lucia: Are you sure?
Lucia: 我感觉那一块只有一些烘焙原料
Lucia: I feel like there are only some baking ingredients there.
Shure: 不他那一大碗就是麻酱
Shure: No, that big bowl is the sesame sauce.
Lucia: 啊哈我再看一眼
Lucia: Ah, I'll go take another look.
Shure: 对那个碗是我卸好的麻酱
Shure: Yeah, that bowl is the sesame sauce I prepared.
Tasha: 啊就带这个带的吗
Tasha: Ah, just bring this one?
Tasha: 确实会有点
Tasha: It might be a bit...
Alice:身上会很多味
Alice: It smells a lot on you.
Tasha: 嗯吃完火锅
Tasha: Yeah, after eating hotpot.
Tasha: 还好昨天
Tasha: Luckily, yesterday
Tasha: 也穿的这身哈
Tasha: I wore this outfit too.
Alice:晚上那个洗一下
Alice: Wash it tonight.
Tasha: 晚吗
Tasha: Tonight?
Lucia: 先放在这大家一会自己
Lucia: Just leave it here, everyone will get it later.
Tasha: 啊人怎么又不见了的感觉
Tasha: Ah, it feels like people keep disappearing.
Lucia: 呃有俩人在楼下
Lucia: Uh, there are two people downstairs.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Alice:他们回来了吗
Alice: Have they come back?
Lucia: 哎不对啊
Lucia: Hey, wait a minute.
Lucia: 应该有三个回
Lucia: There should be three coming back.
Lucia: 回来了应该回来了
Lucia: They should be back, they should be back.
Lucia: 应该有三个人在楼下呀
Lucia: There should be three people downstairs.
Tasha: 这边这个为什么都冒气
Tasha: Why is there steam coming out from this side?
Lucia: 嗯他是不是要把火再开大一些
Lucia: Hmm, should we turn up the heat a bit?
Alice:这是不是已经最大了
Alice: Isn't it already at the maximum?
Alice:摘不了了
Alice: It can't be adjusted anymore.
Alice:这个水比这个水多一点所以他慢一点
Alice: There's more water in this one, so it's slower.
Tasha: 可能这边受热不均匀
Tasha: Maybe this side isn't heating evenly.
Tasha: 你看它这个圆圈在这里
Tasha: Look, the circle is right here.
Tasha: 它这个圆圈
Tasha: This circle.
Shure: 知道为什么吗因为
Shure: Do you know why? Because...
Tasha: 这样
Tasha: Like this.
Alice:因为爱情
Alice: Because of love.
Shure: 它的功率大一点
Shure: It's because it has more power.
Shure: 哈哈哈没有什么为什么
Shure: Haha, there's no specific reason.
Shure: 哦好
Shure: Oh, okay.
Alice:这个水还少呢
Alice: There's less water in this one.
Shure: 是因为那个
Shure: It's because...
Shure: 我后来不是把开水几乎都加在这边了
Shure: I almost added all the boiling water to this side.
Tasha: 哦这边加的是开水
Tasha: Oh, you added boiling water to this side.
Shure: 所以他开水加的多一点
Shure: So this side has more boiling water.
Alice:晚上就熏入味了
Alice: It'll absorb the flavor by tonight.
Lucia: 哎拧下开了他打开了
Lucia: Hey, turn it on, it's open.
Shure: 有酒能不喝开玩笑
Shure: Having alcohol and not drinking? Just joking.
Lucia: 已经把朗姆酒打开了
Lucia: We've already opened the rum.
Alice:看来这马上要没了
Alice: Looks like it's almost gone.
Alice:没存储现在已经快3小时了
Alice: No storage, it's been almost 3 hours now.
Shure: 橙汁补满螺丝棋子
Shure: Refill the orange juice, screwdriver.
Alice:只有20
Alice: Only 20.
Tasha: 呵呵这是什么
Tasha: Haha, what's this?
Tasha: 哦好吧
Tasha: Oh, okay.
Shure: 好喝的小甜水
Shure: It's a delicious sweet drink.
Shure: 一些酒鬼
Shure: Some liquor.
Alice:上面有水吗
Alice: Is there water on top?
Shure: 有啊没有
Shure: Yes, no.
Tasha: 喝可乐就行
Tasha: Just drink cola.
Tasha: 中午的可乐
Tasha: The cola from noon.
Tasha: 我觉得火锅应该喝可乐
Tasha: I think hotpot should be paired with cola.
Shure: 可乐有
Shure: We have cola.
Shure: 还有啤酒要吗
Shure: Do you want beer too?
Tasha: 小孩来这桌哈哈
Tasha: Kids, come to this table, haha.
Shure: 还有soda water
Shure: We also have soda water.
Shure: 气泡水
Shure: Sparkling water.
Tasha: 椰子水也有
Tasha: We also have coconut water.
Shure: 筷子拿了么
Shure: Did you get the chopsticks?
Lucia: 你没有吗
Lucia: You didn't get any?
Alice:你要水不要
Alice: Do you want water?
Alice:我去拿一瓶
Alice: I'll go get a bottle.
Tasha: 要什么
Tasha: What do you want?
Alice:水
Alice: Water.
Alice:我去拿哦
Alice: I'll go get it.
Tasha: 你可以拿对
Tasha: You can get it, right?
Tasha: 然后对你不喝饮料吗
Tasha: And you don't drink any beverages?
Alice:还有啥需要拿上来的
Alice: Anything else we need to bring up?
Tasha: 筷子有了
Tasha: We have chopsticks.
Shure: 想起来啥拿啥
Shure: Just bring whatever you remember.
Tasha: 是不是少啊
Tasha: Are we missing anything?
Shure: 楼下还有筷子
Shure: There are more chopsticks downstairs.
Tasha: 哦还有碗是不是够
Tasha: Oh, and bowls, do we have enough?
Alice:碗够吗
Alice: Do we have enough bowls?
Lucia: 碗够了
Lucia: We have enough bowls.
Tasha: 碗和筷子就行了吧
Tasha: Bowls and chopsticks should be enough, right?
Lucia: 八个碗吗
Lucia: Eight bowls, right?
Alice:拿筷子呢
Alice: What about the chopsticks?
Shure: 筷子筷子都拿上来吧
Shure: Bring all the chopsticks up.
Alice:都拿上来
Alice: Bring them all up.
Lucia: 现在有一二为
Lucia: Now we have one, two...
Shure: 反正是8个人
Shure: Anyway, there are 8 of us.
Lucia: 什么是5根筷子
Lucia: What about five pairs of chopsticks?
Tasha: 他拿走了一根
Tasha: He took one.
Tasha: 那就是四双
Tasha: That makes it four pairs.
Lucia: 哦你拿走了一根
Lucia: Oh, you took one.
Lucia: 我以为你拿走了一双呢
Lucia: I thought you took a pair.
Tasha: 四双筷子
Tasha: Four pairs of chopsticks.
Tasha: 还差四双
Tasha: We still need four pairs.
Alice:那我先去拿
Alice: I'll go get them.
Lucia: 我刚想说你倒的好像很多
Lucia: I was just about to say you poured a lot.
Lucia: 但我以为是你比较能喝
Lucia: But I thought you could handle it.
Lucia: 那个气泡酒能开吗
Lucia: Can we open that sparkling wine?
Shure: 气泡酒开了就得喝了今天
Shure: If we open the sparkling wine, we have to finish it today.
Lucia: 确实哦因为气泡酒加橙汁很好喝
Lucia: True, sparkling wine with orange juice is really good.
Shure: 怎么路边的野花不是不要采吗
Shure: Aren't we not supposed to pick roadside flowers?
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Lucia: 突然串台了
Lucia: Suddenly off-topic.
Shure: （歌词）带你去海边
Shure: (Lyrics) Take you to the seaside.
Shure: （歌词）去留住这个瞬间
Shure: (Lyrics) To capture this moment.
Shure: （歌词）在来不及挽回之前
Shure: (Lyrics) Before it's too late to turn back.
Shure: 开饭啦可以吃喽
Shure: Dinner's ready, let's eat.
Alice:叫了嗯但是无动于衷
Alice: I called them, but they didn't react.
Tasha: 无动于衷
Tasha: No reaction.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 再无动于衷咱就开吃
Shure: If they don't react, we'll start eating.
Shure: 不等他们
Shure: Not waiting for them.
Shure: 惯着他们
Shure: Spoiling them.
Shure: 一天天的
Shure: Every single day.
Alice:先没有筷子
Alice: No chopsticks yet.
Shure: 吃饭都不积极
Shure: Not even eager to eat.
Alice:你要尖筷子还是圆筷子
Alice: Do you want pointed or round chopsticks?
Tasha: 啊呃
Tasha: Ah, um.
Alice:只有一双圆筷子
Alice: There's only one pair of round chopsticks.
Tasha: 那就是好
Tasha: That's fine.
Tasha: 那我就要这双特殊的圆筷子
Tasha: I'll take the special round chopsticks.
Tasha: 不我还是要尖筷子吧
Tasha: No, I'll take the pointed ones.
Alice:那我也要
Alice: Me too.
Alice:我要跟你一样
Alice: I'll have the same.
Alice:算了我用圆的吧
Alice: Never mind, I'll use the round ones.
Alice:因为尖的我可能夹不住
Alice: Because I might not be able to hold food with the pointed ones.
Lucia: 我也来一点
Lucia: I'll have some too.
Shure: 高点
Shure: Higher.
Lucia: 哈哈对
Lucia: Haha, yes.
Lucia: 不过我不敢倒你那么多
Lucia: But I don't dare pour as much as you.
Shure: 哎好了好了可以了
Shure: Hey, that's enough, enough.
Shure: 你为什么不用杯子呀
Shure: Why don't you use a cup?
Lucia: 啊因为我懒
Lucia: Ah, because I'm lazy.
Tasha: 现在不给直播了
Tasha: We're not streaming now.
Alice:但是他们好像都知道结果了
Alice: But it seems like they all know the result.
Tasha: 我不知道结果嗯呵
Tasha: I don't know the result, hmm.
Shure: 来点嘛雨轩
Shure: Come on, Yuxuan, have some.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Katrina: 喝喝
Katrina: Drink, drink.
Lucia: 就是橙汁加朗姆酒
Lucia: It's just orange juice with rum.
Shure: 好像橙汁不够
Shure: Seems like there's not enough orange juice.
Shure: 你其实对你们都喝不出来什么味
Shure: Actually, you guys can't really taste anything.
Lucia: 啊太小看人了吧
Lucia: Ah, don't underestimate us.
Shure: 选个片吧选个片吧
Shure: Let's pick a movie, let's pick a movie.
Shure: 别让我的大脸在这地方待着
Shure: Don't let my big face stay here.
Shure: 太太可怕了
Shure: That's too scary.
Tasha: 是一个独立的国家
Tasha: It's an independent country 政治问题
Alice:为什么还是这个龙啊
Alice: Why is it still this dragon?
Tasha: 还是这局
Tasha: Still this round.
Lucia: 把壁纸换了
Lucia: Change the wallpaper.
Shure: 这是我iPad壁纸
Shure: This is my iPad wallpaper.
Jake:啊这个能剥吗
Jake: Ah, can this be peeled?
Tasha: 什么这个能播吗
Tasha: What, can this be broadcast?
Jake:这个能剥吗
Jake: Can this be peeled?
Shure: 怎么
Shure: What?
Tasha: 这为什么不能播
Tasha: Why can't this be broadcast?
Shure: 你还帮忙监督着是吗哈哈
Shure: Are you also helping to supervise, haha?
Tasha: 哦刚刚那段话吗
Tasha: Oh, that last bit?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Shure: 我也很开心
Shure: I'm also happy.
Shure: 因为我有酒喝
Shure: Because I have alcohol to drink.
Lucia: 没事就算橙汁用完了
Lucia: It's fine, even if the orange juice runs out.
Lucia: 咱还有可乐
Lucia: We still have cola.
Shure: 这个兑可乐好喝吗
Shure: Is it good with cola?
Lucia: 自由古巴
Lucia: Cuba Libre.
Tasha: 怎么了
Tasha: What's up?
Lucia: 自由古巴的传统兑法吗
Lucia: Is this the traditional way to mix a Cuba Libre?
Tasha: 这是一道裂痕
Tasha: This is a crack.
Lucia: 这不是老母加可乐
Lucia: This isn't rum and Coke.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice:你这
Alice: You're...
Alice:你这屏幕裂了吗还是膜
Alice: Is your screen cracked or just the film?
Tasha: 不是膜
Tasha: It's not the film.
Tasha: 什么时候开饭
Tasha: When are we eating?
Jake:可以开了是吧
Jake: Can we start now?
Shure: 可以开始了
Shure: We can start.
Shure: 其实摆起来吧咱们
Shure: Actually, let's set up.
Alice:碗没拿过来
Alice: We didn't bring the bowls.
Jake:那就摆起来
Jake: Then let's set up.
Jake:摆起来开
Jake: Set it up and start.
Shure: 然后把这个机器停了吧
Shure: Then let's turn off this machine.
Shure: 别别弄坏了
Shure: Be careful not to break it.
Jake:这个开完就结束录制
Jake: Once we start, we'll stop recording.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Okay.
Jake:开把摆起来
Jake: Start and set it up.
Shure: 到时候没喝完的都得带回去
Shure: Whatever's not finished, everyone has to take it back.
Tasha: 哦然后又不不不录了就开始正正哦
Tasha: Oh, then we won't record, we'll just start right away.
Jake:然后就不录对对对
Jake: Then we won't record, right, right.
Alice:啊蚂蚁爬上来了
Alice: Ah, ants are climbing up!
Jake:这怎么开
Jake: How do you open this?
Jake:这叫刀划吗
Jake: Do you use a knife to cut it?
Jake:哎在哪
Jake: Hey, where is it?
Jake:有有刀是吗
Jake: Is there a knife?
Shure: 我还没没确定坐那
Shure: I haven't decided where to sit yet.
Shure: 橙汁不够了
Shure: We're running out of orange juice.
Shure: 可能有点浓
Shure: It might be a bit strong.
Shure: 啊可以往里兑氧和毒
Shure: Ah, we can dilute it with some water.
Lucia: 这个也开了吧要不
Lucia: Should we open this one too?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Choiszt: 卧槽两个锅这么豪华
Choiszt: Wow, two pots, so luxurious.
Jake:8个人两个过合适吧
Jake: Eight people, two pots are just right.
Choiszt: 合适太合适了
Choiszt: Perfect, absolutely perfect.
Lucia: 特别合适
Lucia: Absolutely perfect.
Choiszt: 8个锅才合适
Choiszt: Eight pots would be just right.
Lucia: 这这好紧啊
Lucia: This is so tight.
Jake:看你直播
Jake: Look at your live stream.
Choiszt: 那内个刀开一下
Choiszt: Can you open that knife?
Lucia: 啊好
Lucia: Ah, sure.
Lucia: 谢谢我看看有啥人能直接撕的
Lucia: Thanks, let me see if anyone can tear this open directly.
Shure: 我们看点什么
Shure: What should we watch?
Lucia: 这是不能撕开啊
Lucia: This can't be torn open.
Shure: 我们看点啥
Shure: What should we watch?
Lucia: 这能撕开耶
Lucia: This can be torn open!
Tasha: 是你们3个人的绿豆糕
Tasha: These are mung bean cakes for the three of you.
Tasha: 因为你们3个刚刚不在
Tasha: Because the three of you weren't here just now.
Choiszt: 哦谢谢这是你做的吗谢谢
Choiszt: Oh, thanks. Did you make these? Thanks.
Tasha: 呃你猜
Tasha: Uh, guess.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 可以试
Lucia: Can I try?
Jake:这是一个好问题
Jake: That's a good question.
Jake:一款可以问PUA
Jake: This can be asked about PUA.
Choiszt: 你要做得就好吃
Choiszt: If you make it, it'll taste good.
Katrina: 谢谢
Katrina: Thank you.
Choiszt: 期待你做的
Choiszt: Looking forward to your cooking.
Lucia: 虾滑就下的时候再撕吧
Lucia: Let's tear the shrimp paste when we're about to use it.
Lucia: 呃这这这咋放呀
Lucia: Uh, how do we place this?
Jake:这个也可以撕
Jake: This can be torn too.
Katrina: 刚才他不是
Katrina: Didn't he just...
Jake:这个怎么
Jake: How about this...
Jake:这是这是那个
Jake: This is, this is...
Lucia: 这是那个豆皮啥的应该
Lucia: This is that bean curd or something, I guess.
Shure: 腾讯会员
Shure: Tencent membership.
Shure: 我有没有来着
Shure: Did I get it?
Lucia: 咱为啥买了两个毛肚哎呦妈
Lucia: Why did we buy two beef tripe? Oh my god.
Shure: 经典搞笑是吧
Shure: Classic comedy, right?
Alice:这撕了吗
Alice: Did this tear?
Shure: 吓得我特烦恼
Shure: I was so scared, really annoyed.
Lucia: 呀
Lucia: Ah!
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn.
Lucia: 撕了撕了
Lucia: Tore it, tore it.
Lucia: 但是它里面还有个袋子
Lucia: But there's another bag inside.
Jake:随便看看
Jake: Just take a look.
Jake:这段不录你爱怎么
Jake: This part isn't recorded, do whatever you want.
Lucia: 我知道外面这层撕了
Lucia: I know the outer layer is torn.
Jake:哎不对
Jake: Wait, no.
Lucia: 里面那可能是我也不知道它啥意思
Lucia: There might be another layer inside, I don't know what it means.
Jake:有一圈摄像头在录
Jake: There are cameras recording.
Lucia: 下的时候再撕还是什么吧
Lucia: Tear it off when it goes down or something?
Shure: 就是要放能播的是吗
Shure: So we need to put something that can be broadcasted, right?
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: It's fine, it's fine.
Jake:放脸能播的
Jake: Put the face that can be broadcasted.
Jake:go Pro还在拍
Jake: The GoPro is still filming.
Lucia: 真真的吧
Lucia: Really, really?
Tasha: 素毛肚吧
Tasha: Vegetarian tripe, right?
Jake:就是你你在塞博吃火锅
Jake: Yes, you're having hot pot in Cyber.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Choiszt: 真的真的
Choiszt: Really, really.
Nicous: 看一下配料表
Nicous: Check the ingredient list.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Alice:洗一下吗这个
Alice: Should we wash this one?
Lucia: 不知
Lucia: Don't know.
Choiszt: 洗一下吗
Choiszt: Should we wash it?
Shure: 不干不净
Shure: Dirty and clean.
Shure: 吃了没病
Shure: Eating won't make you sick.
Lucia: 我哎
Lucia: Oh wow.
Lucia: 我以为他这种包装都是直接吃的嘞
Lucia: I thought this kind of packaging was ready to eat.
Choiszt: 我也以为
Choiszt: I thought so too.
Lucia: 不了解
Lucia: Not sure.
Choiszt: 十八点三杀就是毛肚
Choiszt: Eighteen point three kill, it's tripe.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 给大家表演一个人类洗毛肚啊
Shure: Let me show you how humans wash tripe.
Jake:可以记下来
Jake: You can write that down.
Lucia: 啊你真的系了
Lucia: Oh, you really did it.
Tasha: 把这个包
Tasha: Wrap this up.
Lucia: 记一些高光时刻是
Lucia: Note down some highlights.
Alice:这个没有吗
Alice: Doesn't this one have it?
Choiszt: 方便你们
Choiszt: It's convenient for you guys.
Tasha: 所以我们决定两边一起共用
Tasha: So we decided to share both sides.
Shure: 经典不知道看什么时候
Shure: Classic, not sure when to watch.
Shure: 就看点夏洛特烦恼
Shure: Just watch some "Goodbye Mr. Loser."
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Choiszt: 不用急不用急
Choiszt: No rush, no rush.
Nicous: 我也没开始记
Nicous: I haven't started noting down yet.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake:迭代一下
Jake: Iterating.
Jake:还没迭代
Jake: Not yet iterated.
Jake:迭代迭代
Jake: Iterate, iterate.
Jake:多换几个
Jake: Swap a few more.
Jake:人气就一直很嗨
Jake: The popularity will stay high.
Katrina: 啊你看一下你哎
Katrina: Ah, take a look at this.
Choiszt: 没有吗空调你开吗
Choiszt: No? Are you turning on the air conditioner?
Jake:开空调吗
Jake: Turn on the air conditioner?
Lucia: 我直接我建议我直接用碗喝水了
Lucia: I suggest I just use a bowl to drink water.
Lucia: 所以一会就用这个碗吃
Lucia: So, I'll use this bowl to eat later.
Jake:遥控器在哪啊空调
Jake: Where's the remote for the air conditioner?
Lucia: 嗯好问题
Lucia: Hmm, good question.
Alice:是不在那个沙发上那个是吗
Alice: Is it on that sofa over there?
Katrina: 黑色的是吗
Katrina: The black one?
Jake:白色
Jake: It's white.
Shure: 黑色是电视
Shure: The black one is the TV remote.
Alice:是不是开空调的时候放下去了还是
Alice: Did you put it down when you turned on the air conditioner, or...
Shure: 这也不是
Shure: It's not that.
Shure: 这是那什么的
Shure: It's for something else.
Jake:放下去了吗
Jake: Did you put it down?
Shure: 这呢这呢
Shure: Here it is, here it is.
Shure: 这呢我放这了
Shure: Here, I put it here.
Jake:瞅一瞅去找一找啊
Jake: Take a look around, go find it.
Alice:是吗
Alice: Really?
Jake:这个像确实像
Jake: This looks like it, it really does.
Shure: 就这就是
Shure: This is it.
Lucia: what's this
Lucia: What's this?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 谁调到22度我妈妈在家不揍你
Shure: Who set it to 22 degrees? My mom would scold you at home.
Shure: 26度调好了
Shure: Set it to 26 degrees, done.
Jake:保护地球
Jake: Save the Earth.
Jake:人人有责哈哈哈
Jake: Everyone's responsibility, hahaha.
Shure: 就是这你说录进去多不好啊
Shure: Seriously, recording this is not good.
Shure: 我们还用空调
Shure: We're still using the air conditioner.
Katrina: 我道歉
Katrina: I apologize.
Shure: 他真的一点听不到哎
Shure: He really can't hear anything.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈我们仿佛在看默剧一样
Shure: Hahaha, it's like we're watching a silent movie.
Jake:嚯这确实经典
Jake: Wow, this is classic.
Jake:来我们干个杯
Jake: Come on, let's have a toast.
Jake:就come杯
Jake: Just come and have a drink.
Lucia: come杯
Lucia: Come, cup
Jake:有有杯子吗
Jake: Do we have a cup?
Katrina: 哇我可是
Katrina: Wow, I could...
Alice:多了
Alice: There are plenty.
Jake:好好杯子
Jake: Okay, good, cups.
Shure: 应该喝不出来什么
Shure: Probably can't taste anything.
Jake:我要把我爸把我茅台打上来
Jake: I'm gonna bring my dad's Maotai.
Shure: 吧
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 那边一个这边一个
Shure: One over there, one here.
Katrina: 这有人做吗
Katrina: Is someone doing this?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Huh?
Lucia: 这儿老板
Lucia: Here, boss.
Shure: 你往你往这边
Shure: You, come over here.
Shure: 我们挤一挤
Shure: Let's squeeze in.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Katrina: 老板坐这
Katrina: Boss, sit here.
Shure: 中间串一个
Shure: One in the middle.
Choiszt: 这般一个还少一个
Choiszt: One here, still missing one.
Tasha: 他不用看电视
Tasha: He doesn't need to watch TV.
Tasha: 他要观察志愿者
Tasha: He needs to observe the volunteers.
Choiszt: 这什么电视电影
Choiszt: What kind of TV show is this?
Shure: 夏洛特烦恼哈哈
Shure: It's "Goodbye Mr. Loser" haha.
Choiszt: 高中还演过
Choiszt: We even performed it in high school.
Tasha: 还演过
Tasha: You performed it?
Choiszt: 你猜我演的什么
Choiszt: Guess who I played?
Shure: 你演的是圆滑
Shure: You played the smooth-talker.
Choiszt: 不是
Choiszt: No.
Alice:这个车标
Alice: This car logo...
Choiszt: 我演的是演的是
Choiszt: I played, I played...
Lucia: 玛莎拉蒂
Lucia: Maserati.
Alice:他演了这个烧饼
Alice: He played this bun.
Lucia: 哦哈哈
Lucia: Oh haha.
Jake:干杯吧
Jake: Cheers.
Shure: 干杯
Shure: Cheers.
Jake:干杯
Jake: Cheers.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 你喝这个呀
Katrina: You're drinking this?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 啊那还行
Lucia: Ah, that's fine.
Lucia: 那我拿这玩意也不是那么突兀
Lucia: Then holding this thing doesn't seem so odd.
Jake:哈哈哈确实
Jake: Hahaha, indeed.
Lucia: 哈哈哈谢谢你哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha, thank you, haha.
Jake:来干杯
Jake: Let's toast.
Jake:干杯
Jake: Cheers.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Jake:干杯
Jake: Cheers.
Shure: eagle life票房大卖哈哈哈
Shure: May Eagle Life be a box office hit, haha.
Jake:来药房大卖
Jake: To a booming pharmacy business.
Jake:哈哈哈大卖卖
Jake: Hahaha, huge sales.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahaha.
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈
Tasha: Ahahaha.
Shure: 希望点击百亿啊
Shure: Hope it gets a billion clicks.
Tasha: 这不是开源开源产品吗
Tasha: Isn't this open-source?
Jake:卖卖卖
Jake: Sell, sell, sell.
Katrina: 上万star
Katrina: Tens of thousands of stars.
Jake:对上万star
Jake: Yes, tens of thousands of stars.
Jake:这个可以
Jake: This is good.
Jake:专业这个专业
Jake: This is professional.